okay this is sick so nuts um statistics
have shown that if Amazon stays on the
same trajectory that it's on right now
by 2026 Jeff Bezos is set to be the
first trillionaire in the world how many
billions is that any one thousand
billion a thousand billion that's one
thousand one thousand billion dollars
it's so hard to fathom how much money
that is
it's insane it's insane mmm it's it's I
mean hold on
you'd be the first trillionaire in the
world yeah
I can't believe daddy didn't get to a
trillion can I have a like can you do
very free 30-days again yeah I have two
trillion bro thirty-three come on it's a
ton of money thirty three times a
thousand that's thirty three thousand
because because of Miglia billion
seconds is thirty three years a billion
seconds that's a thousand billion yeah
what's that comparison it was amazing
three thousand years really a million
set a billion seconds 1 billion seconds
is about 33 years and then 1 million is
like so a trillion seconds is 33
thousand years that's how much money he
has a trillion seconds
$70 just 34% of a year I'm sorry I'm
sorry
Dru's 34 percent every year the last
five years it's well what what he from
what I've heard and a guy who wrote a
bacillus sniper I yeah but the guy said
he's he's very very intent on creating
charities and doing something very good
with that money
like really good with that money he's
not gonna keep it all yeah what are you
gonna I'm it's real you could never
spend what do you know I mean look at
that so a million a million seconds
there's only about 11 days yeah 11 days
in a billion seconds is 32 years yes
that's how that's what I'm that's the
difference but yeah so now
and then take a billion it's a thousand
billion I have a thousand billion
dollars what the [ __ ] are you talking
about how much money do you have I have
a thousand million dollars that's nuts
but by 2026
what do you do you Liam comes with huge
responsibility you have to make the
world a better place you got to figure
out it and everyone wants a piece of
something well yeah I mean
so as of Honk's role as a Thursday
morning he was worth 143 billion
compared to last year he's worth 28
billion that's it huge I guess it
becomes exponential everybody needs it
it's this some guy puts Jeff Bezos about
to become the world's first driller
while we're about to enter a depression
Djoser goes this is a bad place that's
just chick and I'm president did 30
million Americans have unemployment
numbers still grown but Cohen a few guys
making him a trillionaire I mean well he
will he's got to figure out here Jeff
Bezos well sometime in the near future
have more money than the Netherlands
totally normal nothing out order here
okay
come up with Amazon though I tell you
this right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch
your tongue oh good what's gonna happen
what are you gonna do use some of that
boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]